and with us in Syracuse New York hi Ann
how are you hi Dave I'm better than I
deserve how are you today
just the same how can I help oh good I
have a question for you about to Bible
verses I've come across recently my
husband and I are FPU coordinators and
we're on baby step 7 so we definitely
know plenty of Bible verses that are
anti debt we're not going to change our
stance on debt based on what I'm about
to ask you so I'm not about to go back
into that don't worry but I'm just
hoping you can help me understand these
verses because they're not negative
about debt or lending they're actually a
little bit positive which kind of
confused me okay you want to hear what
they are sure Matthew 5 42 gives to the
one who asks you and do not turn away
from the one who wants to borrow from
you okay look stop just saying go to
your I go to your Hebrew and Greek and
look up the Greek on the word lend
tomorrow I don't know and what you're
gonna find is it's another version of
give okay because what it's doing is
picking up the King James English and
it's not not picking up the actual
interpretation of the Greek and because
it's in other words that verse if you go
back and read a couple verses on either
side of that one what you're gonna see
is the whole spirit of the thing in
context is all about loving other people
well not making it not making them your
slave and so this is not this is not
like an excuse for the banking business
to be existence you're not you're not
being adversarial I understand that so
but it's just the spirit of lending
there is like it you would you ever have
somebody say I want to borrow a cup of
sugar right but they never but they
never bring it back no okay it's that
issue
yeah it's that kind of cannot borrow at
issue yeah yeah yeah you know can I
borrow some toilet paper please don't
bring this back yeah and so you know
that kind of stuff right so it's that
kind of a thing it's that kind of a
borrowing and lending it's not a it's
not a transaction like a bank
I'm running out of time but right quick
tell me what the other one is I'm dying
is it Genesis yeah they wanted now the
other one is Psalm 112 5 it's probably
exact same problem but it's probably
from the Hebrew good will come to those
who are generous and learn freely yes
their affairs with justice
yeah again go pull your Hebrew on that
and your what you're going to find there
is is that you give that cup of sugar is
lending I'm gonna lend you a couple of
sugar and I don't expect it back really
and that's where usery laws in the Old
Testament come into play as well so hey
good question I love having those
discussions appreciate you calling in
and thanks for leading the class